vous imaginez bien sûr que je suis pas
venu ici pour mentir intérêts de mentir
ici 0 à part avoir des gens qui vont
contre enquêté pour que je sois dans une
mer de noirs dans trois semaines c'est
suicidaire que de raconter ce soir un
seul micro mensonge
les dessins que vous dites serait de moi
non ils sont deux mois les dessins sont
de moi je vais vous montrer trois choses
et vous avez accepté de les montrer qui
n'excuse en rien mes dessins évidemment
je vais revenir avec toutes les
questions sur ses dessins sans tabou
avec une franchise totale
j'aimerais en prélude à ce qui va se
passer maintenant c'est à dire la partie
la plus désagréable de la soirée vous
montrer ce que je lisais dans mon
enfance et de mon adolescence alors je
sale excuse rien parce que je joue dix
mois pour moi on se connaît si vous
étiez vraiment aux antipodes de
l'antisémite bien au contraire mais je
le cerveau fob de tout ce que je déteste
voilà et c'est vrai que vous étiez au
contraire vous étiez pour moi un exemple
là dessus voilà et c'est vrai que là je
suis tombé de très haut quand il s'y est
bien et eric lepleux en témoigner s'il
ya bien quelqu'un qu'on a reproché de
trop en faire sur ce sujet alors vous
imaginez bien que maintenant on me
reproche d'avoir ce trophée pour cacher
ça mais c'est ça non mais bien sûr mais
c'est le cercle vicieux c'est le sable
mouvant dont je parlais tout à l'heure
mais et je vous dirai tout à l'heure
pourquoi c'est impossible que je sois se
moque ce que certains ont cru que
j'étais d'ailleurs antisémite je vous
dirai pourquoi c'est impossible
mais si on sait bien engueuler souvent
écrit d'ailleurs on n'est pas couché
c'est sur ce sujet mais j'aimerais en
prélude non pas en excuses en prélude
vous montrez 3une que j'ai lu l'enfant
de trois numéros de charlie hebdo lac
était dans le contexte dans lequel vous
avez écrit les années 70 et 80
alors 3 une de charlie hebdo donc
dessins de caral hic est un génie total
ouais à une époque où tant mieux s'en
sortir mais c'était sur le confie
j'avais 10 ans 19 ans de la cité voilà
donc enfin on peut le dire hitler super
sympa salut j'ai loupé un sagaz oui
voilà et voilà ce qui représente 18
c'est la seule chose que j'avais pour
moi et c'est vrai que là ça va ça va
quand même très très heureux du violon
sam est très très très violent c'est
vrai que là alors il vous met 3 une sont
extrêmement violente et c'est une et
jean et j'en suis heureux un pain
goodbye
imaginez cyril c'est une ne sont plus
possibles aujourd'hui mais et j'ai nommé
justian juste pour
revenir juste là c'est une c'est une
race et de la caricature c'est charlie
hebdo c'est voilà c'est le cc voilà ça
mais attendez comme vous n'aurez sans ce
soit lors des qualifs c'est sa part
exactement la tradition de charlie hebdo
se moquer les re lisez ça on des digues
l'air de cinq noms raquel welch en
hitler saga et on va voir je crois aussi
vie main et gourio et moi ça me fait pas
rire du tout non mais attendez je vais
vous expliquer montrons si c'est
possible
wolinski est un juif c'est charlie hebdo
c'est ce qu'on va voir où hitler égaler
celle de ville magouilles alors s'il
vous plaît ce qu'on peut voir une pierre
égaler celle ci voilà voilà voilà film
de 1987 c'est la bande dessinée qui m'a
inspiré
les c'est ça qui m'a inspiré ce à
enlever ça d'ailleurs derrière parce que
moi il faut l'enlever hélas hélas si
j'ai quelques minutes pour m'exprimer
c'est important pour moi c'est important
et je sais que ce soir je peu nuancée
des choses et j'en suis vraiment heureux
et après toutes les questions je vous
assure on peut déposer
je ne suis pas en train de vous dire le
ils l'ont fait donc j'ai droit de le
faire
eux ce sont des génies et effectivement
raquel ils l'ont fait dans un certain
contexte dans une certaine tradition et
avec aussi un certain talent mais ce
talent aujourd'hui il n'en reste pas
moins qu'il est plus supportable pour
toutes les raisons qu'on sait chaque
époque a ses travers et je me réjouis
que ses dessins ne puisse plus être
possible aujourd'hui
les dessins hitler égalé 16 villemin
était déjà inadmissible à l'époque la
bande dessinée était interdite le jour
même précisément c'est ça qui m'avait
attiré quand j'avais 20 ans et c'est
d'autant moins pardonnable ce que j'ai
fait que j'étais quelqu'un de cultivé à
20 ans je moi j'ai beaucoup de si vous
voulez je peux pardonner
j'ai beaucoup d'indulgence pour les gens
de 20 ans en général mais je n'en ai pas
pour mon cas particulier parce que mon
cas particulier celui de quelqu'un qui
avait lu jd tolstoï tôt quelqu'un qui
cultivait ce que je prétendais être ne
tombe pas là dedans j'ai imité ces gens
là mais pour des raisons évidentes à
qu'entre fin avec le recul du temps
c'est par hasard
j'étais tombé dans un trou noir pour
plusieurs raisons j'ai fais maths sup
maths spé
parce que mon frère pense que j'ai tout
réussi je montrais ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a échoué pendant toute une
partie de sa vie j'ai échoué à
polytechnique à centrale et aux mines
j'ai fais maths sup maths spé pour rien
rien deux ans de ma vie pour rien
ensuite je fais prépa hec j'échoue hcg
choix le cpg chou et l'essec
je me retrouve à sup de co reims pour
moi l'école est très bonne et j'ai vécu
à l'époque comme une humiliation
je me suis fait quitter par une femme
qui ne me supportais plus je la
comprends aussi je me suis retrouvé dans
un état de désespoir et je crois que
j'ai eu une seule volonté suicidaire les
temps incapable de me faire aimer
j'ai décidé de me faire haïr
et ces dessins m'ont permis de franchir
des caps n'ont pas dans la subversion
parce que la subversion c'est positif
dans la transgression et dans la
transgression il ya une dark side à
quelque chose qui est pas net
et là où je suis pas du tout indulgent
pour moi c'est parce que la question
intellectuelle qu'on peut se poser c'est
est-ce que la transgression n'est pas
une forme de l'antisémitisme
l'antisémitisme est quelque chose qui
mute tellement facilement on connaît d
antisémitisme déicide politique
religieux intellectuelle sociaux
financiers qui me prouve à moi même que
le type café des six dessins ne lance ne
l'était pas moi je me vide la manière
suivante les dessins sont antisémites je
l'étais pas mais la vraie question c'est
que faudrait la fouille et la question
est est ce que quelqu'un qui s'amuse
avec ses frontières là est ce que ça
veut pas dire quelque chose et cette
question me hante la question qui manque
c'est parce que je l'étais ou pas les
dessins leçons mais la question qui me
hante c'est comme quand on dit j'aurais
collaborer j'aurais résister moi la
question qui monte c'est ce que j'aurais
résister collaboré pendant la guerre est
là qui sans qu'il me manque depuis très
longtemps c'est par les dessins avec
lesquels on menace régulièrement chaque
fois que je fais quelque chose de bien
ce qui me fait peur c'est que j'ai pas
l'épreuve qu'à l'époque je n'étais pas
si ça se trouve je l'était et ça prouve
à quel point
quelqu'un qui en état de grande
fragilité peut avoir des tentations
ignoble parce que ses dessins quand je
les vois aujourd'hui ils me font mais
alors tressauter vomir ils sont
insupportables d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup
de lecteurs qui me disent qui a présenté
des excuses à la communauté juive et
cetera
il ya des dessins terrible sur les
éthiopiens donc ce soir je présente mes
excuses c'est tout à fait normal à la
communauté noire dans son ensemble au
handicap et à tous ceux qui ont soutenu
l'an de l'abbé pierre parce que je
faisais à l'époque et fait feu de tout
bois
j'ai pas une obsession sur les juifs feu
de tout bois
tout ce qui pouvait me faire haïr je
prenais l'été station ne soit même et je
ne cherche absolument aucune excuse et
aucune indulgence simplement mon travail
à un état intellectuel était de
m'arracher à cela et cyril c'est la
première fois que je dire ça ici de ma
vie je viens d'une famille raquel où on
ne parlait pas des arabes ont parlé des
[ __ ] je viens d'une famille on
perd l'une disait tous ces connards sur
un bateau on coule le bateau c'est pas
une grosse perte
madame du cloud j'ai une mémoire de
phénoménal c'est mon seul à sa qualité
que fait de lire toute la journée en c1
avait dû cloud me convoque enfin
convaincre mes parents votre fils dit le
mot [ __ ] toute la journée je me
fais frapper le soir même pourquoi tu a
répété ça mes parents n'ont jamais
prononcé une phrase antisémite jamais
mais les [ __ ] les [ __ ] les [ __ ]
mais vous diront que non parce qu'ils
ont des amis homos et une malveillance
sur l'être humain
mon ancienne petite amie et maria qui
m'a accompagné ce soir et brésilienne
elle est métisse devant l île on dira
oui les brésiliens vous avez la danse
dans la peau
mon père a vu un jour un homme prendre
sa place moment les gars et réponse de
mon père et ben voilà le noir là je te
foutrais tout ça dehors les [ __ ]
sommes dit mon père à la kalachnikov au
lance flammes j'ai entendu ça toute ma
vie raquel je préfère avoir fait le
chemin de m'arracher à cette gang à une
gang de gens qui mériteraient d'être en
prison pour les violences qu'ils ont
commise et une violence verbale et jeu
je suis fier de mon parcours
j'en ai marre de toujours jouer les
modestes j'en ai marre de toujours venir
me faire hara kiri présenter des excuses
toute la journée
mon parcours il est exemplaire j'ai eu
du mal être tolérant j'ai eu du mal à
aimer j'ai du mal à me faire aimer jésus
magie joie en train de jouer les
calimero c'est fini ce soir j'ai
présenté des excuses à des communautés
que j'avais oublié de citer à dire fois
parce que c'est tout à fait normal qu'il
y ait des gens qui souffrent quand vous
avez été martyrisé vous êtes l'ami des
noirs êtes l'ami des juifs et vous êtes
l'ami des homosexuels toute ma jeunesse
je me suis traité de [ __ ] de sale [ __ ]
parce que je disait marcel proust et que
je les ai andré gide et la seule chose
que mon père connaissait jeet c'est que
c'était un sale [ __ ] donc s'ils
voulaient aujourd'hui pour des raisons
viscéral j'ai mis vingt ans de
psychanalyse à comprendre que j'avais un
enfant battu je ne supporte plus dans ma
chair les propos antisémite xénophobe et
les propos racine même raciste si dans
ma chair je suis l'ami de tous les
persécutés même des chatons qu'on
persécute des animaux et je vais
peut-être trop loin et que moi vous
savez connaissez ma véhémence mais au
bout d'un moment
stop c'est fini et j'ai donc ce soir que
toute personne qui est un signe aura un
signera de près ou de loin que je suis
antisémite sera poursuivi par la justice
j'ai passé 25 ans
à me battre auprès de la communauté
juive c'est vrai que c'est mon combat
j'ai c'est un combat qui m'est cher j'ai
étudié on n'étudie pas le talmud
on n'apprend pas l'hébreu parce qu'on a
peur de se faire choper pour des
desseins on le fait pour des raisons
profondes et intimes
j'ai lu maïmonide j'ai lu le garant de
vilna j'ai lu benny lévy sans frime avec
un petit comité d'étude parce que dans
le dans le judaïsme
on ne travaille pas seul et ses textes
j'ai été les chercher au fond de mes
tripes
je termine juste sur une phrase j'ai
longtemps cru que j'étais bête parce que
j'étais nul en mathématiques la judéité
ne m'intéresse pas le judaïsme ne
m'intéresse pas le philosémitisme je
m'en méfie parce que les fils de ces
mythes sont des antisémites à l'envers
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la pensée juive
quand j'ai commencé à étudier je me suis
dit mais tu es intelligent fait et tu le
savais pas enclaver jamais dit parce que
le les l'hypothétique au déductive it et
des mathématiques la physique
newton des cartes marre je suis pas fait
pour ça ce qui m'intéresse c'est
l'esprit d'escalier ses airs et oublier
les conclusions oublier les origines
arrêtez de démontrer se perdre dans les
textes la littérature m'a sauvé et la
pensée juive aussi